hot breath hey another writing tip
that the part the setup
is necessary you cannot do it without
the setup did i lose you
oh i'm here no i can't see you
uh oh you can't can you see me
i can see you you look okay i can see
that mustache and all its glory
um but you have to do the setup
and but once you've put in that work the
setup's not getting you a laugh it's the
setup
once you get the punch line it drives me
crazy to see a comic that will do a long
setup and get a laugh
and then move on to another setup and
i'm like crap you've put in the work
now that you're you've got it set up
instead of getting one laugh
really go look at this thing and say you
know
is are there two labs here are there
three laps here are there four laps here
because you've set it up you know
and and so learn to dig deeply you know
the
terports critical thinking thinking to
the next level the next level on the
next level
and but and that's how bits grow longer
so if you've got a funny premise and it
gets a good laughing you
then start thinking all right can i stay
here a minute is there
is is there more to dig out of this hole
and and that's how a funny joke turns
into a bit
turns into holy cow have you heard her
15-minute bit on the grocery store or
whatever
yeah so yeah man well be conscious as
you're writing
all right i've done the work i've set
the joke up
are there more laughs that that i can
get while i'm at this spot
how do you find those laughs is it
asking questions is it looking for
funny analogies yeah what do you do to
find those laughs i mean sometimes
sometimes it's analogies
again you know like for me i might
write the word down like you know
anything the kid in the grocery store
and then i start
you know again i'll go what do kids do
in a grocery store
well you know they grab stuff off the
shelf they beg for stuff
they you know they it and so i'll just
start writing that
down and and and and just seeing
all right if i can take this i got a
funny joke about this but
can i get two more jokes can i get three
more jokes out of this and now i've got
a whole bit i don't just have a joke i
got a whole bit
about this and but for me that's what
works as i just write it down on a piece
of paper and i'm like
just everything associated with